You know Christian, I love that cube exercise, and and
the things that the students came up with was just
wonderful but, I mean, so what? I mean, it's, it's,
you can't do anything with it. What's the use of it?
>> Well, the use is in helping students understand what it means to be
a designer, what it means to actually
design these affordances. And the signifiers that.
>> Yeah, but I'm worried. So many designs I see
are this wonderful cube and one thing, but they actually
nobody can understand them when they don't function very well.
>> Well function is only part of it. I mean you, you've gotta bring
in the other human elements too. I mean of course there's meaning and function.
>> Yeah.
>> And then there's usable, it's also delightful. So
the real trick is to combine them. So we've
been talking about things like affordance and constraints and
that makes it very functional and usable and understandable
but it's not necessarily interesting.
>> And conceptual models, like how do you actually know how to use something.
>> Yeah, but that doesn't, so what you're trying to tell
me, the cube model is about making it more than that.
>> Yeah, and we're living in an era when this object, the
phone, wasn't very much ten years ago, wasn't much to talk about.
It did things for you, it made phone calls. But now it's
become a big part of your life, and a lot of that.
>> Is the enjoyment of using it.
>> Yeah, and designers have made it even
delightful at times. So what we have to do is we have to manage
to combine the wonderful fun with the
cube, with the functionality of the other principles.
>> Yeah, and that's how you do design, it's about all these
things, and you've now taken the first steps at designing the world yourself.